معنى الان من القاهره الدكتور احمد
المندري المدير الاقليمي لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه لشرق المتوسط نرحب بك دكتور
المندري كيف تتابعون هذا الوضع
الصحي الوضع المدنيين الانساني وايضا ما
يتعلق بوضعهم الغذائي
حياكم الله يا اختي انتصار وجزاكم الله
خير على الاستضافه وكل عام وانتم بخير
اهلا طبعا كما تفضلتم الوضع الصحي في
السودان وضع مقلق ومروع جدا حيث ان يعني
ما يقارب من عشرين مستشفى في عموم السودان
والمناطق التي فيها النزاعات وبالاخص
الخرطوم اغلقت ابوابها يعني واقفلت عن
العمل هناك ما يقارب من 12 مستشفى معرضه
كذلك للتوقف عن العمل اما بسبب الهجمات
العسكريه المباشره او بسبب نقص الكادر
الطبي بسبب الارهاق او بسبب نقص
المستلزمات الطبيه وانقطاع الكهرباء
وانقطاع امدادات المياه والوقود كذلك هناك
ما يقارب كما تفضلتم في التقرير حوالي 16
مليون سوداني وهو ما يمثل ثلث سكان
السودان يعني
يعتمدون على المعونات الانسانيه هناك ما
يقارب من حوالي 50 الف طفل يعانون من نقص
تغذيه حاد ويحتاجون الى عنايه يعني
متواصله خلال 24 ساعه ولاسابيع لاستعاد
عافيتهم هناك ما يقارب من 24 الف امراه
سودانيه نتوقع ان يعني
تكون في وضع الولاده خلال الاسابيع
القادمه معرضات للخطر ولا قدر الله للوفاه
بسبب اغلاق المؤسسات الصحيه وكذلك عدم
مقدرتهم الوصول الى المؤسسات التي هي
مفتوحه هناك ما يقارب من واحد واربعه من
عشره مليون يعني امراه فتاه معرضات كذلك
لمشاكل صحيه هناك مخاطر ظهور فاشلات كحمه
ضنك والملاريا وشلل الاطفال والامراض التي
تصيب الاطفال كذلك بسبب توقف التوقف برامج
التحصيل للاطفال وبرامج الترصد الوبائي
كذلك لمختلف الاوبئه التي يعني تتوطن في
السودان اليوم منظمه الصحه العالميه ما
الذي هي بصدده لمساعده
المدنيين السودانيين لدعم هذه المستشفيات
التي توقفت عن الخدمه لتوفير الدواء
العلاج وما شابه للسودانيين الذين يحتاجون
في هذه المرحله
لكل الامور التي تتعلق بالمنظومه الصحيه
فعلا طبعا احد الخيارات يعطي انتصار في
مثل هذه الحالات هو المستشفيات الميدانيه
ولكن للاسف بسبب فقدان الامن وسلامه
العاملين الصحيين لن نتمكن من ذلك ولكن
نحن نقوم منذ اللحظات الاولى يعني الفرق
المختصه في مكتب المنظمه في السودان
بالتعاون مع المكتب الاقليمي في القاهره
والمكتب الرئيسي في جنيف من تدريب
العاملين الصحيين قمنا بذلك حتى قبل هذه
الازمه بسبب الوضع الهش للنظام الصحي في
السودان تدريب العاملين الصحيين في كيفيه
التعامل مع حالات الطوارئ الاصابات قمنا
بتوفير المستلزمات الطبيه والتي كانت
موجوده لدينا في مخازننا في السودان بفتح
تلك المخازن وتمويل المستشفيات الصحيه
بالتعاون مع وزاره الصحه وكذلك المنظمات
الاخرى قمنا بتوفير
مستلزمات طبيه في المخزن الرئيسي اللوجستي
في دبي للمنظمه ونحن على استعداد لنقل تلك
المستلزمات بالتعاون مع شركات الطيران
سواء في الامارات او في مصر العربيه جلوس
مصر العربيه او شركات الطيران التي يعني
نعتمد عليها قمنا كذلك بتقييم الوضع من
اجل نقل تلك المعونات او المستلزمات
الطبيه عن طريق البحر من خلال ميناء بورت
سودان حيث ان المطارات اغلقت يعني لم
يتبقى لنا مدخل جوي امن قمنا كذلك بتوفير
موارد ماليه حتى نتمكن من توفير احتياجات
لازم ما يقارب من حوالي 4 مليون دولار تم
توفيرها حالا هناك طبعا مناشده للداعمين
الدوليين بتوفير ما يقارب واحد وسبعه من
عشره مليار دولار تحتاجها السودان حاليا
في اسرع وقت ممكن والتي يعني للاسف لم
نتمكن من توفير الا ما يقارن 13% من هذه
المبالغ التي يحتاجها النظام الصحي في
السودان نعمل على توفير مستشفيات خارج
مناطق النزاع والتي تعتبر امنه ولكن للاسف
الطرقات غير امنه فلذلك لا نريد ان نضحي
بحياه المواطنين وكذلك حياه الموظفين في
الامم المتحده او في وزاره الصحه هذا عن
الداخل السوداني متى عن اللاجئين هناك
توقعات
بخروج
الالاف من اللاجئين السودانيين الى بلدان
اخرى مجاوره هل هياتم الظروف هل هناك خطه
معده لهذا الملف
نعم هذه نقطه مهمه الانتصار طبعا كنت
شخصيا بالتواصل مع مديره المدير الاقليميه
لمكتب افريقيا من اجل التنسيق مع المكاتب
القطريه في المناطق او الدول المجاوره من
قاره افريقيا للسودان قمنا كذلك بالتنسيق
مع المنظمات الامميه داخل السودان
كاليونيسيف والمنظمه الهجره والسكان منظمه
الامم والطفوله او قصدي منظمه المراه
والطفل وكذلك المنظمات الاخرى المعنيه
بملف الصحه من اجل ضمان حصول هؤلاء
النازحين والمهكرين على خدمات صحيه هناك
ما يقرب كما ذكرتم في التقرير حسب
البيانات التي لدينا عشرين الف مهاجر او
لاجئ الى تشاد وهناك عدد كبير كذلك الى
مناطق اخرى ومن ضمنها طبعا الى جمهوريه
مصر العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك من القاهره
الدكتور احمد المنظري المدير الاقليمي
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه لشرق المتوسط